here's an exercise that we are going to
engage in before we take our next break
ranking these college duos who have been
reunited at the nfl level their impact
on
the 2021 season in cincinnati it's joe
burrow and jamar chase miami tuatanga
vailoa and jalen waddle philadelphia
jalen hurts and devonta smith and
jacksonville
trevor lawrence and travis atn
rank those for me one through four
impact this year oh okay i i actually
think how we have it here on this
graphic i would definitely go one two
right there i think i would make trevor
lawrence and travis etn three and jalen
hurts and devonte smith four you know i
just i think to start there with the
jalen hurts devonte smith conversation
there's just too many unknowns for me
right now to buy on to that you know the
team's kind of in a rebuild mode it's a
new offense we know jalen hurts has his
questions about throwing and things like
that so i got to see more there for me
to bump him up in front of those other
guys
i'm i'm expecting the most out of
out of borough and chase
that that's what i do yeah i mean we've
seen them connect already you know we
know burro is legit and belongs in the
nfl and as a star
you know so i think that's my clear one
two is to a and waddle yes there's
talent there but i think they're two for
the obvious reasons right i mean we both
need to see more from tua and to see if
he can kind of take that next step in
development in his football game make
some more explosive plays throw the ball
into tighter windows so that's why i go
with him there and then hey the rookies
the clemson rookies
i don't expect them to little a lot of
football games but i still expect them
to be dangerous on the offensive side of
the ball trevor lawrence is gonna have
an impact because he's really talented
and he's gonna
make us pay attention to jacksonville
and i'm excited to see atn because he's
got that alvin kamara skill set and
you've brought it up and like we've
talked about how he's been playing some
slot receiver too right so i'm kind of
interested to see how they use him and
their their plan of attack so i guess
that would be my ranking there what do
you think about that
at the rookie mini camp he was
exclusively lined up yeah
so they're going to get this guy on the
field this question james robinson or
travis atn you're going to get your best
11 guys on the field
[Laughter]
you don't got anything more to say there
i'll let you i'll let you carry that one
home if you want no i'm just joking i'm
just joking but what about you the 11
the 11 best players with an asterisk do
you see that do you like those i agree
with you on burrowing chase yeah i don't
know about yeah
i still
look we want to be good i this i hate
having to talk about tua but
i i think back to his comments from last
week when he said he didn't know the
offense very well i you know i i want to
put tua and jaylen wado at two but
hey i don't know yeah i know i
i think there's a gap between borough
and chase and whoever is two i'll go
i'll hear you there
too
and then with hurts and smith hurts
didn't make your top 40 list and for all
we know they're gonna get the sean
watson between now and the time the
season starts in philadelphia i think
they're very ambivalent about jalen
hurts jalen hurts was
in some respects
look
whatever happened last year with carson
wentz somebody in that organization
must have thought it was possible or
they wouldn't have used a second round
pick on a quarterback yeah period right
right
they must have thought it was possible
and it happened and now jalen hurts is
the guy who's there backed up by joe
flacco and they got to ask themselves
where do we go from here and i i don't
know that i saw enough from hertz in his
limited time last year to say he's going
to be throwing the ball all over the
place and devonta smith is going to be
catching it and doing the things that he
did in the
national championship game so i i guess
i would put
i would put hurts and smith at four and
lawrence and atn at three okay all right
here wait one more question i know we
got to go to break but come on it's june
2nd we can talk okay cool pete said
we're cool
our next segment's filler anyway so we
can keep talking you're you're a funny
guy you're a very funny guy it's the
quarterback is it not 40. yeah no it's
not no it's not oh no
after okay yeah yeah all right so we
have so we have two filter segments
coming up all right
so but all right i want to say this
because i had a coach say this to me
uh last week and i i wanted to bring
this up to you or at least get your
thoughts
you talked about tua we want to like tua
right he's he is he's charismatic he's
got that great lovable smile i root for
him without a doubt
but
like
do you think because of that he got away
with those comments last week i i think
i think there's some people in around
football that look at it like if other
rookie quarterbacks had said that or
done that in the past
there have been a way bigger bachelor
backlash but because it's tua and he's
just likable guy
you know people were just like oh he'll
be better this year
you know that that's not a bad take
because from our perspective there was a
certain amount of relief because it's
like okay now we understand why he got i
know right he didn't get bench because
he stunk he got benched because he
didn't know the playbook well is that
any better i i know that's that's kind
of what the coach i was texting with
made the point like
we what else did kyle have to say
you're funny i haven't talked to kyle uh
so but no you just texted with him
i did actually talk to him for the first
time on sunday this past week i won't
lie i did so there you go i did talk to
him okay facetimed him and saw him and
everything there but no this was
somebody else and it kind of brought up
that same point where but you you you
said it right where it's like oh yeah
like oh yeah oh we feel better now now
that we know what happened but it was
like but it's still like
wait you're the fifth pick of the draft
you didn't know the plays and the
offense what were you doing you know
that was kind of the point that this
person was trying to make to me and i
was kind of like damn i wish i would
have said that on the show last week
because that is definitely part of the
story here
yeah no our reaction was
we had a certain amount of relief
that it it's not that there's some sort
of hard cap that's already been placed
on his physical abilities so there's
still hope he's going to become whatever
the dolphins thought and you know people
get mad at us dolphins fans get
triggered because we're not
leading the tuatanga viloa parade saying
he's already dan marino and it's just a
matter of time before they retire number
one we gotta see it
and last week's candid
confession by tua made us feel like ha
there's still hope but yeah look it
wouldn't take much time to put together
a list of quarterbacks who would have
been destroyed that's what i mean if
they said that that's where this guy
went down too he made it he kind of saw
you guys what if right whatever what if
another guy
who got benched a couple of times last
year
and had a rough experience in new
england were to come out and say
you know i just didn't know the playbook
very well last year what would people
say if cam newton made that same
admission
i know i know it'd be
it's all we'd be talking about it's all
we i think there's other rookie
quarterbacks we could look at through
the last few years to go oh if that guy
said that there would have been
everybody been like oh he's a disaster
see what's going on here you know so
uh it just shows you sometimes
perception helps the reality of the
situation
that's that's a great point and uh
i i i am surprised that we didn't pluck
the low hanging fruit and i think
i think i understand why we didn't right
and maybe the folks out there who are
watching and listening understand as
well but maybe tua does deserve more
criticism for the
we praised him for being so i know i
know cause who comes out and says that
but yeah others wouldn't have been
praised for being candid they would have
been destroyed for
saying that they didn't know the
playbook regardless of how candid they
were
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports